hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm answering
a question from one of our readers
tsunaide who wrote in he came across my
profile on twitter and here's this
question I've been touring with the idea
of starting up a middle to high-end car
wash but I have no idea on where and how
to start so thanks for the questions
they made here's the thing I hate
spending money till I'm making money and
it's so easy to lose a lot of money on a
business like a car wash because you
have a lot of costs you got to you got
to have a location you got to have
supplies and as much as possible I try
to figure out a way to get started
without spending that money
anybody can spend money right it's easy
to spend money not everybody can make
money and car washes can be successful
but they can also bankrupt people right
it's this cost getting those businesses
going so what I try to do is find a way
again to start it off without spending
too much money you're going to have to
get a little bit of your supplies I
guess in order but I wouldn't spend
money in a location yet if you're
signing up a lease you know you got a
lot of cost that you'll have to carry
for a long time I'd start by partnering
up with another business so find a
company that has a related related
business maybe it's a mechanic an auto
mechanic maybe it's a dealer somebody
who's in the car business and offered to
do car washing service out of their
location and it could does a couple
things first it tells you do you really
want to be in the car wash business you
know better the test it out small see if
you like it see if you enjoyed the
people seeing if you're you know
enjoying this business or not and you
want to keep doing this for the next 10
years or if you get into it and figure
out this sucks you know I don't want to
do this I want to do something else so
you're you're testing it out without
spending a lot of time or a lot of money
especially to get it going
that's first the second thing I'd also
tell you is it'll teach you about the
types of clients you're going to get
it'll teach you about location they'll
teach you about how to write a bill
this we can learn from whoever you're
working with whatever company you're
working out of and it'll more
importantly bring in money that we'll be
able to fund your expansion so if you're
able to start this business off out of a
different location and you're making
some money you know now you have some
money to invest back into the business
your and up to the point where you can
go and get your own location now you're
investing from profits and you're not
pulling out of your your own pockets or
going out and getting a loan and
invested for it I'm putting you know
yourself on the line financially you
know potentially for a very long time
for so that's what I do to start
honestly go find another business in a
related field and find some way to
partner up with them where you're doing
your car wash service out of their
location it's not ideal I know you know
you wanna you have the big vision and
that's awesome but you want to take baby
steps every day and make sure you're
doing something every day to take that
business and make it go forward you'll
figure out if you want to do this
business or not you'll be investing back
into the business from profits and it's
honestly one of the best ways you can go
and build your business a great example
just to tell you is my wife's company is
a salsa business and she started by
working at a gym so she teaches people
how to dance if she'll teach 6,000
people here in Toronto how to dance
salsa and it's easy to go up and and
spend money on this right you can go and
buy a look an office or rent an office
and and drop tens and tens or hundreds
of thousands of dollars on this location
and how nice it is but who knows what is
going to work or not who knows if you
even like this business or not so she
started by renting location space out of
gyms so she partner up with local gyms
who have extra space at night a one room
and she paid them for that room and
she'd build up the business and she
found that she really enjoyed doing it
and built up enough of a nest egg then
she can go in a fourth to go and get her
own location and it took a while to do
it but she's building from profits she
has a huge successful business and she
made sure that she really enjoyed it
before expanding that company so
hopefully that helps you know
just try to honestly try it out and and
get those partnerships going it's going
to save you a lot of time headache money
and [ __ ]
so those you're watching you like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
I love seeing us come in and makes my
day and lovelier yet to think please
leave a comment under underneath the
video if you have a comment about this
video or a question for your own
business
I'd love be able to try to answer for
you so thank you and I'll see you in the
next episode
you